know if you're a huge fan of like the up
series 57 and up and mmm of course my
collab Ted um can we talk about like the
evolution of reality TV because some say
that was the first real look at reality
TV but I think you know talking about
that was even earlier I will tell you
and it's funny because I'm now working
on something with someone who had worked
on that first series if you look back at
reality television it really started
with and because we expect we're always
expanding the definition of reality
television
so now we've absorbed game and we've
absorbed variety into the reality thing
a little bit where there are some
reality competition shows where while
you're winning a prize and you're
competing so is it a game show or is it
a reality competition show using that as
the yardstick you would go back to Ted
Mac's original amateur hour which was
the first show on the air even before
candid camera came on the same year but
it beat it by several months the Ted Mac
same original amateur hour was the very
first so a competition a reality
competition variety style show was the
very first thing after that we got
candid camera which came from the radio
series candid microphone which started
in 47 and then started on television in
48 you start moving forward you hit
certain marks like the loud excuse me an
American family which is 1973 if I'm
remembering correctly and was very it
was very early I think they shot it in
71 and it finally aired in 73 I could be
wrong I don't remember my dates exactly
that's when you start to see reality
where you're actually just doing follows
and you're seeing people interact with
each other
and it's sort of the precursor to the
way that we we have a lot of those types
of shows like the real world now the
real world of course being its own big
mark in 1992 you have cops which came
out of the 1988 writers strike sort of
as an answer to well what are we going
to do when we have a show when we can't
have writers on it so we're going to
make this thing cops was enormous
and then you know you can still watch it
you have America's Funniest Home Videos
which I don't think anybody ever thinks
about is a reality show because it's
primarily it's it's a clip based thing
but everything that's happening there is
really happening it's just documented
documented reality clips that are being
sent in like things that are really
happening to people there's a business
model I which I wish I would have
thought of Vindobona every day I just
think about that guy and how amazing you
know he was to figure that one out and
then of course you hit mm then you start
to see survivor and those types of shows
it's constantly evolving and the
different types of shows are constantly
you know they're changing and new things
are being introduced
we're hybridizing a lot of things now so
we have a reality competition show
that's a little bit about this but it's
also got elements of this so you have
Big Brother which is sort of like if you
had competitions in a real world house
where it was about you being eliminated
you know that's not the only thing
that's different we're just really
continuing to grow and evolve and figure
out who we are in reality so there's a
lot of stuff we haven't done yet we're
starting to get into that place where
again I talk about it all the time
because I can't shut up Anthony Bourdain
it's one of the few examples I've seen
of a reality show that is one person's
voice throughout the show he is on
camera he is writing all of his own
material for that show he's not
maneet Lee his voice in that show which
makes it better than so many things that
are written by 15 layers of committee
and everybody's kind of putting their
two cents in and you're you're writing
host copy that may or may not be exactly
how the host would normally sound
beautifully done stuff but we're going
to continue to get better and evolve and
in make television that is not as your
earlier comment or positive garbage
you